[Music]
good morning
it's seven o'clock you're watching sky
news breakfast now today
questions and condemnation over a video
released of the journalist detained in
belarus but
will international sanctions help free
him
and covet hot spot confusion will ask
the work and pension secretary therese
coffey about new restrictions that local
leaders say
have come out of the blue plus
one year since george floyd was murdered
we'll speak to the man in this picture
that made headlines during the black
lives matter protests and
ask him if anything has changed
[Music]
singing in the rain how choirs are
harmonizing their call to be
allowed to practice inside it's tuesday
the 25th of may confession criticism
the father of a journalist detained in
belarus says his son was forced to
appear in this video
to admit organizing mass protests
gobsmacked local leaders claim new
guidance restricting movement and mixing
in copied hotspots
slipped in under the radar
calling for justice campaign has marked
one year since george floyd's murder
in the special program we asked if the
brother of the murdered london teenager
stephen lawrence what needs to change
has anything changed has people's
mindsets change
i think the one thing that sticks to my
mind is people
still feel like in certain corners their
voices are not being heard
falling further behind because of a
pandemic new figures reveal how
lockdowns
have led to more of the most
disadvantaged pupils
skipping school
a very good morning to you the father of
the journalist arrested after a
passenger plane was forced to land in
belarus says he believes his son
has been forced to record a confession
video admitting to organizing mass
protests
the video shows roman proteseovitch in
the police station in
minsk saying he's being treated with
respect
u.s president biden said forcing the
plane to divert was an outrageous
incident
as the eu announced new sanctions
against belarus calling it an attack on
european sovereignty aleister bunker
reports
this was the last photo taken of roman
protosavich
just before he boarded the ryanair
flight in athens he was arrested
along with his girlfriend when their
flight was forced to land in belarus
nothing was heard from him for 24 hours
and then this video was released from
his prison
in minsk yesterday evening
my name is roman protosavic yesterday i
was detained by belarusian police at the
airport
now i'm in minsk police station one i
can say that i don't have any health
problems with my heart
or any other organs i'm being treated
with respect
and according to the law right now i
continue to cooperate with police
and confess to organizing mass protests
in minsk
my son cannot admit to creating the mass
disorders because he didn't do any such
thing
it's unlikely he went for a deal with
the prosecutors
i think it's just that he was forced to
record the message
we especially can't understand exactly
when the message was recorded
and how truthful it is
international outrage has come thick and
fast first
the uk banned belarus's flag carrier
from landing in britain
and uk airlines from flying over
belarus's airspace
and then late last night the eu
announced the same
we will not tolerate that they play
russian roulette with the lives of
innocent civilians
this evening in the first part of our
meeting we reacted very quickly as was
necessary given the events
this is an attack on democracy this is
an attack on freedom of expression and
this is an attack
on european sovereignty and
this outrageous behavior needs a strong
answer
the us is on the same page but is yet to
announce any punishment for belarus
although president biden has described
the incident as
a direct affront to international norms
and has hinted at sanctions to follow
lithuania has told its citizens to leave
belarus for their own safety
speculation about russian involvement
hasn't been confirmed
but presidents putin and lukashenko are
reportedly due to meet
later this week the belarusian leader
has very few allies now aleister bunkel
sky news
well let's head to brussels and our
europe correspondent adam parsons i mean
certainly adam the eu
seems to be taking a a very strong line
much stronger than the uk has taken
well european union is worried about
belarus and it's worried about
lukashenko
for a whole panoply of of reasons
number one is that in the minds of many
diplomats here he is a rogue
leader he is simply unaccountable and
doing things that have
taken the eu by surprise the idea
of aviation piracy of forcing a
passenger jet out of the sky is
completely unpalatable
in their minds and also the suggestion
that he isn't just
close to vladimir putin but these are
the idea that actually there were kgb
agents on this flight at the same time
raises the specter
of this country which sits between the
eu
and russia
there were sanctions against uh
alexander lukashenko
there will be more we know that they
have created this this no-fly zone
effectively over belarus they have uh
sanctioned
uh individuals they have banned the
belarusian national airline from flying
uh over the eu but i think they are now
considered
considering a package of even tougher
sanctions the question
is how to sanction mr lukashenko without
damaging the dissidents within belarus
who they want to support
okay adam thank you well let's talk to
the working pension secretary
teresa coffey who joins us from
westminster it's good to see you this
morning look
the eu certainly seems to be pushing a
much harder rhetoric
on belarus than the uk is at the moment
do we need to get in step with that
well i think the foreign secretary set
out to parliament yesterday uh the
sanctions that we are putting in place
but it's important to have coordinated
effort which is why
we are working with other countries to
condemn this completely
and utterly unacceptable behavior and
we'll continue to do so
i'll be prepared to go further well i
know that
uh the sanctions already in place uh the
foreign secretary will continue to
review
what further actions may be needed uh
but uh we will continue to work with our
partners
uh to condemn this activity and to make
sure the
situation is restored as quickly as
possible what's our view
that you're the the uk's view of
lukashenko is he a legitimate leader in
our eyes
well the um what i would say is that we
do not accept the behavior that's been
demonstrated by
the leader of belarus uh we will
continue to condemn that
uh i'm not going to get into various
more diplomatic
situations more than what the foreign
secretary had already set out to
parliament yesterday
okay uh look this video of roman
protestovic that has been released is
there any credence to that and what he
says in it
i don't know the answer to that stephen
so you're not i mean his father says
it's been coerced which i mean look
wouldn't come as any great surprise
would it uh
i don't think it would come as any
surprise but i don't i'm not in a
position to tell you
uh exactly what uh our latest
intelligence is on
the coercion or not of this but all i
can say is the behavior of the belarus
regime
does not lend itself to think that in
any way this statement was offered
voluntarily
it's important that we follow through
with the sanctions and working with
other partners
in order to get this situation rectified
as quickly as possible
this huge this is this whole thing is it
is a huge concern isn't it because as
we've seen
with the sanctions which which were
applied last year when they don't seem
to have made
any significant difference and as adam
parcel wasn't saying this
you know even the possibility that kgb
agents are on the plane i mean
this country which is a key link between
effectively europe and russia it raises
so many questions i mean
is this really sort of pretty near the
top of the agenda for government at the
moment
well as the defense secretary set out
the other day the threat from russia
is a constant one which is why we are
continuing to invest in our
defence infrastructure in order to kind
of tackle that
but what i would suggest is it's the
concerted action where we are working
together with our partners
from europe and elsewhere in order to
step up the action against the
belarusian regime
and we will continue to work together to
do that
can we have a chat about the covid
situation um because there's this new
guidance we've become aware of
guidance for areas linked to the indian
variant
um i mean they're effectively local
restrictions aren't they
well i think when the prime minister
talked about the issues of the co
indian variant last week uh for kovid
that he
said that we need to be extra cautious
in certain areas
including those where we had sent in as
a public health england
extra surge testing and the guidance is
entirely just in line with that
and was issued last week uh you know we
are on regular contact with the councils
and communities in that area so this was
just about more formalizing
on the record the guidance that would go
alongside the need to be extra cautious
in making sure we get a grip of the
situation of this particular
variant yeah but i mean as you say the
guidance was introduced last week it was
introduced
on friday but there was no official
government publicised
announcement the labour mp for bolton
south east says she's gobsmacked by the
advice and wasn't given any notice
whatsoever
well as i've said the prime minister had
laid out that we need to take extra
caution
in certain areas in regarding the indian
variant it's
a good practice to have formally put
that guidance on the record
affecting those communities as i say
we've been working in close contact
i'm surprised to hear uh that people
think this is uh
sort of come out of the blue it hasn't
it's about formalizing uh on the record
the guidance
which we believe people can and should
follow in order to make sure that we
tackle
uh the the not to have more spread of
the indian variant
while a lot of people would support that
and you know taking whatever action is
necessary i mean
the concern here seems to be that this
has been introduced under the radar
because it's not just
yasmine qureshi it's it's other local
leaders and public health officials in
these key areas
are saying they just didn't know so in
terms of the importance of clarity
in everything we do in relation to covid
why didn't the government just make it
clearer what was going on
i think the government has made it clear
it published formal guidance
it was focusing on particular
communities where we've seen a
significant increase in the transmission
of this variant that's why resources
have gone in to do such
testing and to encourage more people to
get the vaccination
so this is just a part of a coordinated
effort and the guidance is
simply a formality recognizing the
people wanting to be need to be need to
be extra careful
in those communities in particular where
the issue is has been spreading
i'm pleased to see that more people have
taken up the the vaccines
uh you know it's important that people
get the jabs it's important that people
take the special precautions that we
want to
see to reduce the transmission otherwise
there could be
more problems in that community so far
we haven't seen the impacts because of
the efforts by the community
and all the guidance does is simply
formalize uh what was already
effectively happening in practice in the
locality but i mean
the problem is we're not going to see
any impact from this guidance are we for
a number of weeks we know it's a sort of
about two to three week lag before
any data comes through and yet the prime
minister seems keen to make an
announcement
on june the 21st pretty quickly i mean
ultimately this could still impact june
21st couldn't it and that
that opening up of the whole country
well stephen we've always been clear
that
we wanted to make sure we had all the
relevant data that's why
we're holding off publishing some
further uh information
simply because we're still gathering
more data to understand the impact
of the indian variant it's important
that we do that
but i expect the prime minister will
still be in a position to
make an announcement in early june but
we need to continue to make sure we
collect the relevant data
understand the effects of what's
happening in the variant understand the
effects of what's happening
with what we've the guidance that we've
given to people
and it's important that people continue
uh to
follow that and also uh the basics as
well as
getting their vaccination i mean i know
there's this there's this huge demand
for normality
after june the 21st i don't think there
is anybody in the country who doesn't
understand that desire from the public
and from government and all of this
but we are getting these reports that
that even people who are
fully vaccinated which is going to be a
majority of people in the country by
then
and are still going to have to
self-isolate for 10 days or two weeks if
they come into contact
with someone infected by covid after
june the 21st now
that seems a little bit
counter-intuitive doesn't it
well stephen i'm conscious there are
there's a headline in one particular
newspaper today
i strongly suggest to people that they
wait to hear from
uh from the prime minister from the
chief scientist from the chief medical
officers
in order to understand what is happening
uh we're not in a position to say that
yet
you know it's really important that
people continue to respect ronin
step three uh we're not in step four yet
as we've always said it's going to be
driven by data and updates
but i think the important thing is that
we are starting to see a return to
normality people can go out
but we still stress that the uh sorry go
out into restaurants and
pubs and similar and go into other
people's households
where the guidance is is clear on that
but it's important that we still stick
to the basic rules
you know there's sorts of things that we
want to get people focused on is getting
people back into work
making sure whether it's we've got a
particular scheme where we've now got
100 000 people
getting that tailored support to try and
take advantage of the vacancies
this is all part of the road map to
recovery so getting on with the jabs
getting on with
getting people ready to take up the jobs
but we still need to be careful at this
stage covert has not gone away
and things like the indian variant and
what we've seen is a recognition of that
but also recognition of the actions that
we've been taking collectively and with
communities
in order to try and get a grip on this
and localize any outbreaks and really
try and get a grip of it
in terms of getting people back to work
and the job entry targeted supports the
238 million pounds scheme
you reckon there's a there's a hundred
thousand people on the road to getting
back into it into another job now i mean
is that going to be money well spent or
or
is there are you is the expectation that
this is actually going to start helping
perhaps a million people or so i mean it
seems 238 seems a
an awful lot of money for a hundred
thousand jobs
well i think if we can get uh the number
of people back into a number of people
back into work by using that extra
tailored support
it's for people who've been out of work
already for three months uh
some of the initial perhaps help they've
been getting hasn't quite worked
and we are starting to see people get
jobs and that's important that
people continue to realize or take
advantage of extra support
in order to get that particular job it's
been such a tough time we've focused a
lot on young people and kickstart
but actually it's people of all ages
that we need to help to try and get back
into work
and to take advantage of the
opportunities and job vacancies that
really are opening up
minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you stephen
well as we were saying there there is
some new guidance for people living in
covid hot spots affected by the india
variant so let's have a look at the
latest covid figures for you and they've
been
2 439 new cases of covid19
in the uk along with three more deaths
reported
that means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
is now 127 724
meanwhile another 126 357 people have
had their first vaccination
252 1139 have had their second
and in total very nearly 61 million jabs
have been administered across the uk
that's still to come for you this
morning what more should the uk do in
its response to the detention
of roman protestovich we'll talk to the
former ambassador to belarus nigel davis
at half past seven concerns over
epilepsy drugs and the risk they may
pose to unborn babies will hear from an
epilepsy sufferer about her worries
about having children and at twenty past
eight i'll talk to a gp who set up the
vacci taxi
helping people with problems get their
jabs
now members of george floyd's family are
marching in minnesota to mark the first
anniversary
of his death he died after being held
down by the neck by
then police officer derek chauvin the
march is organized by the group
families supporting families against
police violence which is calling for a
change in policing laws in the state
floyd was my man he was but one man
and there are so many cases that we need
to
reopen not only in this state in this
country across the world we all know
that
well to mark one year since the murder
of george floyd sky news asked stuart
lawrence whose brother stephen was
murdered in a racist killing in london
in 1993
to reflect on the impact of the black
lives matter movement in the uk
over the last 12 months i just wanted to
see how far we have come from
year on you know has anything changed
has people's mindsets
i changed the one thing that sticks to
my mind is people
still feel like in certain corners their
voices are not being heard they saw
injustices they happen over here with
the stop and search figures the definite
police custodies
the layers of the the institutions that
discriminate against you we've got
problems and issues over here as well
we'll bring you a special report
presented by stuart lawrence to
commemorate the anniversary of the
murder
of george floyd that's stephen and
george the killings that inspired a
movement
half past nine this morning and at 9 45
we'll talk to patrick hutchinson the man
whose picture went viral when he pulled
a white protester to safety
from the middle of a black lives matter
protest
let's look at some other headlines for
you this morning and the u.s government
has warned against traveling to japan
for the olympic games because of the
pandemic
the surge of infections in japan has
cast more doubt on whether the games
should go ahead but
japanese ministers say they believe
there's been no change in the us support
for the olympics soldiers in mali have
arrested
their president and prime minister
raising concerns of a second
coup in a year a military coup in august
overthrew
the then president caita and many people
are now concerned that the army intends
to stay in control
the lead singer of the italian rock band
manoskin which won
eurovision has been cleared of taking
cocaine during the show
demiano david returned a negative drug
test after shots of him leaning over a
table
caused a frenzy of online speculation
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken is in israel where he'll be
talking to
the leaders in the wake of the recent
conflict between
israel and hamas alex rossi is in
jerusalem
for us this morning look an important
set of meetings alex no doubt but
does it hold much hope
well stephen these are the highest level
uh talks that have gone on since the
the crisis the 11 days of uh fighting
which saw
much bloodshed anthony blinken arrived
in tel aviv what about an hour ago
he's going to be meeting the israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
and then he'll also be having meetings
with mahmoud abbas the
president of the palestinian authority
which is crucial really because
ties broke down completely during the
trump period
as a result of his unalloyed support
of the israelis now there are really two
components to these talks they're
described as kind of
fairly low-key but we're hearing this
phrase again coming out of the state
department quiet intensive
diplomacy trying to get things moving
but slightly kind of below the radar
they'll concentrate really on shoring up
the truce
it's been in place for a few days now
but it is pretty shaky still
all of the dynamics the fundamentals
which drove the fighting in the first
place
they still exist for instance the the
flashpoint of jerusalem so they'll try
and negotiate around that to see if they
can strengthen it up
the other thing that they will be
focusing on is uh
humanitarian aid into gaza trucks are
starting to roll it over the border with
fuel medical supplies and food but
remember gaza
has been under a military uh blockade
from the egyptian side and also the
israeli side since 2007.
it's always teetering on the brink of a
humanitarian
catastrophe but it's even worse at the
moment so it's key that that aid
keeps flowing in and they'll also i
think discuss
um how to kind of reconcile fata
and hamas possibly which won't be easy
of course
uh the palestinians are not only split
geographically between
gaza and the west bank they're also
split uh politically
in terms of the peace talks i think they
probably won't really do very much
on that at all i suspect anthony blinken
will put out put out feelers and try and
explore
the possibility about how you could
resurrect that but that won't be easy
there isn't a huge amount of hope that
he'll be able to advance that
uh at all and then tomorrow of course
he'll meet other regional leaders the
jordanians
and the egyptians okay alex for now
thank you
now as the country emerges from the
depths of the pandemic
do you figure seen by sky news suggests
there's been a marked increase in the
levels of
truancy from schools disadvantaged
children
are apparently much less likely to have
returned to the classroom
after lockdown one of the worst areas is
chester
there was a 25 increase in persistently
absent school children
our home editor jason farrell reports
this room is a safety net called the
base it's for kids at dunraven school in
south london
who are at risk of dropping out i'm here
because
i was struggling to go to school and i
was out of lessons a lot
jack started going absent from school
because like many he struggled with
adjusting from primary to secondary
he preferred lockdown classes i like
that i could
i was finding the work at home i'm just
sitting on my computer doing it
i think it's when i'm there in real life
i start getting like stressed out and
anxious
zarlene says but for the base she may
not be
here she's come to speak to the support
team because she found coming back to
school
overwhelming and has had panic attacks
being
forced to stay at home 24 7
it's kind of flared up my anxiety
because you're basically chopped
by yourself all the time
with no one to really distract you the
schools notice
that children from disadvantaged
backgrounds are least likely to attend
regularly since lockdown
and parents give a range of reasons the
explanations that are given for example
it's they're really struggling to get
students out of bed and to see the
purpose they've lost a sense of purpose
i think another thing with that is that
they have been staying up very very late
they've got into this pattern of being
so much on phones on their phones or
game playing with others
with other people that's been their form
of contact nationally
post lockdown school attendance levels
look okay but the enthusiasm of some to
get back to class
has masked the drop-off of others much
has been anecdotal but a new
study by think tank social finance of 17
000 pupils in cheshire west and chester
has found a 25
increase in persistently absent children
in the first term of the academic year
and most of them from poorer backgrounds
the key concerns that we've found
is that the children who are
persistently absent are the children we
should probably be most worried about
these are the children that are
accessing free school meals that have
contact with social care
or have got a special educational need
these
children are invisible and we need to
make them visible
london schools in poorer areas are so
concerned that they're forming a new
group of heads called reconnect
london to pool ideas on how to tackle
the problem
i think at heart it has to be about the
relationships
that the young people feel they have
with adults trusted adults in school and
i think if those relationships exist
if the adults in school know how to
develop those relationships and engage
with those young people
you've got a much better chance of
getting them in it's always been
children from disadvantaged backgrounds
who are more likely to skip school
but what this report shows is that that
problem has become
more pronounced lockdown has widened the
attendance gap
and it's those kids on the fringes who
are falling
further away the reasons are complex
saskia desperately wanted to go back to
school i've lost my identity
because i haven't been very social she's
been absent from october last year to
april
because her mother was shielding with
cancer and i'm not very good at
communicating my feelings
so my mum couldn't really help me in
that sense
because i just shut down report authors
say the government shouldn't just focus
on everyone catching up but also
supporting those at risk
of falling out of education altogether
jason farrell sky news
oh she's never absent you never play
truant from this shift
no absolutely not it's my favorite and
only shift
yes so there you go what have you got
for us today
um i've got some weather it's going to
be another cool and breezy one with some
wet weather around
but fear not slowly but surely dry and
brighter conditions are on the way
towards the weekend
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning and i'm going to start with
some good news drier brighter warmer
conditions
are on the way slowly but surely towards
this weekend
but there will still be a bit of wet
weather around but until then we've got
cool conditions
and quite a bit of wet weather to
contend with for today in fact this
morning there are showery spells of rain
across eastern parts of scotland
northern and eastern parts of england
and wales there's also
heavy rain across the southwest of
ireland but elsewhere it's a mainly
bright and fine start for this morning
then going into this afternoon that
showery rain across northern and eastern
parts of the uk will tend to break up
into showers some of which will be heavy
and thundery in between
some bright or sunny spells developing
but overall it will be quite cloudy
across these parts until a little later
as i said some of those showers could be
heavy and thundery even the risk of hail
and across the southwest of ireland
we'll continue with the rain there with
some heavy downpours at times that will
slowly
edge towards parts of the southwest
mainly across cornwall where it will be
a rather wet afternoon but for the rest
of england wales island northern ireland
bar the odd shower or two it's looking
mostly fine and dry but it is going to
be still quite cool for the time of year
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we'll be looking further at
the detention of roman protazovich with
the uk's former man in belarus nigel
gould davis
within a couple of minutes
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
now the father of the detained
journalist and activist roman
protasovich has said he believes
footage of his son confessing to
organizing anti-government protests was
forced out of him well earlier i spoke
to the working pension secretary therese
coffey who told me
it wouldn't come as a surprise if the
belarus regime had coerced the
confession
i don't think it would come as any
surprise but i don't i'm not in a
position to tell you
exactly what our latest intelligence is
on
the coercion or not of this but all i
can say is the behavior of the belarus
regime does not lend itself to think
that in any way this statement was
offered voluntarily
it's important that we follow through
with the sanctions and working with
other partners
in order to get this situation rectified
as quickly as possible
talk now to the uk's former ambassador
to belarus the editor for strategic
survey and senior fellow for russia and
eurasia at the international institute
for strategic studies
nigel gould davis good to see you this
morning look what does the last 48 hours
tell us about mr lukashenko
well the the forced downing of the plane
tells us
that he having been until now a threat
to his own people has become an
international threat
as well it was an absolutely outrageous
and unprecedented
uh event it also shows us uh that he
himself does not feel secure
if he uh has to go to such extraordinary
lengths and encourage national outrage
uh to to detain a single
uh dissident journalist who had been
based overseas
so that tells us something important
about his regime
i think we can be impressed by the scale
and speed
so far of the international reaction the
eu has moved
very quickly on this uh the uk as well
although i hope we will see further
actions announced in due course the
united states is fully behind us
as well so uh it it tells us
that we're now at a a new level of
of confrontation unfortunately in what's
a very difficult situation between
galleries in the west but in terms of of
us
sort of toughening our stance and
presumably potentially more asset
freezing potentially
sort of stronger and wider sanctions
is that going to actually make any
impact i mean as we keep saying as i've
said in the last couple of days
to people but what the the sanctions and
asset freezing we saw
last year do not seem to have made any
difference at least to his
to his political posturing yeah a couple
of points firstly
sanctions are not a magic bullet or not
a switch that you turn on and expect
things to happen immediately
things always take time in international
politics
so we shouldn't be too impatient and
demand
immediate results this is this is slow
steady work
uh the second point is that the
sanctions have been posed so far
have actually been fairly limited for
the most part they've been
largely on individuals as you say asset
phrases and trouble bans and so on
i think given the escalation of
belarus's
outrageous uh activities uh the point is
now to
correspondingly escalate the sanctions
and move from a situation where we're
just imposing
restrictions in individuals to a broader
approach to putting pressure on the
regime
and that means among other things going
after the financial flows
the various ways in which belarusian
state companies are dependent
on access to western finance and western
markets
these are the uh the money flows that
help sustain the regime
so i think it's important now to
calibrate the response make it more
severe
uh in light of what's happened and again
that won't be
a magic bullet it won't have a visual
effects but but it will
make life steadily more difficult for
this regime
psychologically financially so i think
it's the right thing to do at this point
but in terms of the international
response though how
how much will it be in in the minds of
international leaders global leaders
that the close relationship between
belarus
and russia uh well
uh belarus and russia and putin and
lukashenko personally have
long been engaged in a toxic
embrace neither likes the other but
uh in a sense they need each other for
the moment
and it's true that one of the reasons
that lukashenko has managed to stay in
power
uh following the the peaceful uh
out uh burst of uh the demand for for
the democratic change in belarus which
we've seen since last august
has been russian uh financial
support um i'll just say this uh
at this stage there is no clear evidence
yet that russia took part in this
operation but it's something that we
shouldn't rule out
and as the investigation
into this uh uh air incident
develops and as new information comes to
light i think i'm important
to see whether there is actually a
connection there and the implications
would be very serious of course for the
west's relationship with russia
if that were to be the case we know that
there's been cooperation between
the russian and belarusian uh security
services in the past
um let's see if that turns out to be the
case here as well
i mean look you know more about
diplomacy than the rest of us
in terms of how we view lukashenka
should we be viewing him as president as
the legitimate leader
of belarus i think it's right that
western countries have made clear they
do not accept
the legitimacy of the rigged election
last august it was clearly falsified
outrageously so so i i think it's right
not to consider him
a democratic leader and in terms of
of the the action that we can take and
further sanctions i mean there's
in all of this is there's got to be the
consideration of
of what impact this could have on on the
opposition
in belarus does i mean you you've got to
bear in mind that the
the the impact on the people of the
country rather than just the leadership
that's absolutely right and that's a
reason i think
uh for making sure that any sanctions
measures
uh are carried out in consultation
with those who have been so bravely
fighting for their freedom
broadly speaking the direction of travel
of sanctions thinking and practice in
recent in recent years
has been away from imposing a kind of
brute
blunt uh measures that hurt the country
as a whole
towards more targeted smart sanctions
which which go after individuals
responsible
for unacceptable actions and
against the regime that keeps them in
power
so it's right that the sanctions should
uh
seek to pressure uh elites
and power structures while minimizing
the
the the deleterious effects on ordinary
people
so again talk talk to the belarusian
opposition and make sure
that's the case in your design of
sanctions it's good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you
now since george floyd's murder many
athletes have shown their support for
the black lives matter movement with
sports stars taking the knee before
matches
joining marches and taking part in
social media boycotts
our sports correspondent martha kelner
looks now at a year
that has seen sports personalities
making political statements
as never before i will say directly
no i will not go
sport and politics are indivisible
those who take a stand like muhammad ali
refusing to
fight in vietnam have found themselves
exiled
but this was the year protest went
mainstream
naomi osaka the world's highest-paid
female athlete
wore the name of a black woman killed by
police in kentucky
and anthony joshua marched on the
streets of watford
a movement which originated in america
quickly spread
athletes had never exercised collective
power like this
the power of players these days in this
country or in sport in general
i think has only been realized
in the last 12 months since george
floyd's death players realize that
if we want to do something whether it be
support the nhs and give a donation of
our wages whether it be
wearing black lives matter on our shirts
whether it be taking a knee
if all the players are kind of
in unity
there's not really much that anybody can
say in america
the atlanta dream basketball team
protested their own
owner kelly loffler who was also the
state
senator she had called the black lives
matter movement
marxist and divisive and so the players
campaigned for her political
rival reverend rafael warnock went from
being way down in the polling
to being elected these women had helped
the democrats win the senate
when you're in a minority group or in a
group that's
more marginalized like you're inherently
political and you can't do anything
about that so
i think there's a luxury in being able
to say like oh cue politics
out of sports when this affects our
reality and our humanity
it's difficult to believe it's only five
years since american football player
colin kaepernick
was cast aside by the nfl for refusing
to sing the national anthem
in a protest against racism and police
brutality
now brands are actively seeking out
athletes who take a stand
as long as it's genuine if you have a
natural authentic voice
as marcus rashford did then it can have
a very positive impact he
grew up in a low-income family his
mother worked
full-time but still wasn't able to
always put food on the table for them
so he knew exactly what that experience
was like and he was therefore able to
talk about it with
a great level of insight athlete
activism isn't a new phenomenon
but the unrest following george floyd's
murder has
turbocharged the power they wield in
society
their voice has never been louder
martha kellner sky news
well still to come on sky news breakfast
concerns over epilepsy drugs and the
risk they may
pose to unborn babies talk to a couple
of experts in a moment
so we created the book really to
highlight the importance of good
eyesight
and to create something that would cause
people to pause and take a moment to
think about
their own vision the book is entirely
blurred
so every page front cover every
illustration of the classic
um is blurred and we hope that um the
the campaign will raise awareness
as you said we commissioned some
research last autumn which found
that 23 of parents haven't taken their
child
for a sight test um we're committed to
ensuring that people get their eyes
checked regularly
and with children it's so important
because it can have a long
a long lasting effect on their life but
also on their development and their
ability to enjoy
books and reading we we chose the
classic
um from louis carroll particularly
because it may reach out to
parents grandparents because lots of
people probably have very fond memories
of reading the book looking at the
illustrations from their own childhood
there's three things we'd really like
parents look out for us number one
if they notice their child eye is
turning in or turning out
perhaps their child is is more clumsy
has poor hand-eye coordination is a
classic telltale sign
if they're sitting very close to a tv or
screen or holding books
really up close or even concentration
problems
perhaps they were performing well in
class or
and then that's dropped off so now
they're not concentrating for long
periods of time
or or actually their behaviors changed
all um
telltale signs that actually a site test
could be really important
and not all children who go for a site
test end up with losses so a lot of
children have perfect
site leave the opticians not needing
glasses they're only prescribed if
they're absolutely necessary
[Music]
[Applause]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertaining
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to safety
rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
sunny spells will develop this afternoon
but there will be showers again
mainly across northern and eastern areas
of the uk
where they will be heavy and thundery
with hail at times
there will also be spells of heavy rain
across southwest island and the
southwest of england
elsewhere will be mostly fine and dry
but it'll be a cool and breezy day
everywhere
with the generally cool and unsettled
conditions pollen levels will remain
low everywhere again currently small
amounts of grass pollen are now
airborne and oak tree pollen poses a
risk during spells of sunny dry weather
spores will also increase temporarily
after any rain
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers